[موسيقى]
اهلا وسهلا بكم
كالعاده ان تتفاعلون في البرنامج على
صفحتنا على فيسبوك وعلى صفحه البرنامج
قمه العشرين في اندونيسيا ومن خطف الاضواء
في غياب الرئيس الروسي الذي ميرفتن بوتين
هو الرئيس الصيني
الذي تجنب هزيمه كبيره في الكونغرس
العلاقات بين البلدين تدهورت خلال ثلاث
سنوات الاخيره بسبب تناول القوه الصينيه
ما عدا النظر في الزعامه الامريكيه للعالم
وفي كل المعطيات السياسيه للمره الاولى
حسب مسؤول في البيت الابيض جو بيتنا حريص
على اداره الخلافات وتجنب ان تتحول
المواجهه الى نزاع بين واشنطن وبيكين قمه
تاتي في ظروف صعبه تتميز بالحرب في
اوكرانيا ومتى سببت فيه من تضخم وازمات في
مجليه الغذاء والطاقه نهيك عن الاحتباس
الحراري فهل افرز القمه توازنات جديده
خاصه انه ظهرت توافقات بين الرجلين
ومقربات كفيله بان تخفف من الضغط على
اقتصاديات كل الدول من سيفلح في اقناع
الصين والهند بالسير على قوى الدول
الغربيه سعيد بان يكون معي في الاستديو
عمرو والشبكي وهو مستشار مركز الاهرام
للدراسات
السياسيه نقوم دائما بعمليه القنص له كلما
تواجد في باريس همم سعيد بان يكون معي من
بكين همم نادر رانجو وان وهو جميل صحفي
وشكرا على حضورك معنا رغم الساعه المتاخره
في بي كينا ومعنا من واشنطن مسعود معلوف
وهو خبير في العلاقات الدوليه ودبلوماسيه
سابق اهلا وسهلا بكم قبل ان نبدا نستمع
لمقاله بعيدا عن تايوان
لا ينبغي ان تكون هناك حرب بارده جديده لا
اعتقد ان هناك نيه وشيك من جانب الصين
لغزوه حيوان
لم تتغير على الاطلاق
حريص على الالتزام والاحتفاظ بقنوات
التواصل
دائما
معها
المسؤوليه لاظهار ان الصين والولايات
المتحده يمكنهما ادارته خلافتهما ومنع
المنافسه من الاقتراب من الصراع وايجاد
طرق للعمل معا بشان القضايا العالميه
ولكن ما راي الرئيس الصيني
الموقف الحالي الذي تواجهه العلاقات
الصينيه الامريكيه هو مصدر قلق لنا جميعا
هذا الوضع لا يتماشى مع مصلحته شعبيه
بلدينا
ولا يرضي تطلعات المجتمع الدولي
يتعين علينا كقاده الصين والولايات
المتحده ان العب دوران في توجيه وتحديد
الاتجاهات من اجل ايجاد الاتجاه الصحيح
لتنميه العلاقات بين بلدينا
ابدا مع ضيفي من بكين
طبعا انت صيني تعرف عقليه السنين اكثر من
هذا بالتاكيد ولكن الرئيس الصيني عندما
يتحدث بهذه الطريقه هناك نوع من
البراكماتيه يريد
تنقيه الاجواء بطريقه سلسه ومرنه لان
الحديث من ثلاث سنوات هو انه الخلافات
كبيره بين البلديه
من موقف الصين لا تريد
المشاركه في المنافسات الجيول السياسيه مع
الولايات المتحده والسين تريد ان تفهم
الولايات المتحده والعالم ان انه لا يجب
ان نتمسك بالفكره حرب البارده وايضا
اللواء الصفريه فالنجاح الدوله واحده لا
تعني بالضروره فشل الدوله الاخرى فال همم
المنافسه يجب ان يكون منافسه ايجابيه همم
ياتي بالتقدم المشتركه فلذلك همم يعني همم
على همم
الولايات المتحده
همم
العالم كبير يستطيع الاستيعاب التتور معا
لكل الولايات المتحده والسين والاستحار
المشترك فلذلك
يريد ان يعبره تعبره الصين
تدمسك بتنميه سلميه
والسنسه تقدم للعالم فرص اكثر من خلال
تنميه الذاتيه فهذا هو يعني ما يريد ان
يواجه لان السبب التواتر بين البلدين هو
القلق والولايات المتحده او يعتبار
الولايات الصين اكبر تحديدا لها لذلك تريد
زياده التفاهم بين البلدين واا يتجنب من
سوء تفاهم وحتى تجنب من صراع المفتوح
مسعود معلوف يعني كنت تنتظر هكذا موقف من
قبل من قبل
فجاه ان يكون نتحدث عن خلافات يعني ما
الذي حصل مراجعه للاستراتيجيه الامريكيه
ما الذي حصل بالتحديد
اولا تحيه لك عفوا تحيه لك واعتذر
عذرا الرئيس بيدر معروف بانه رئيس يعطي
الدبلوماسيه الاولويه في اعمال خلافا
للرئيس السابق ترامب علينا ان نطلع بان ان
هذا الاجتماع يحصل على خلفيه من الخلافات
القويه القائمه سابقا بين الصين وبين
الولايات المتحده والرئيس بايضا والرئيس
شيشان يعرفان بعضهما البعض فهما كان نائبا
للرئيس في الفتره الماضيه والان بعد ان
استقر الرئيس بالرئاسه بعد الانتخابات
النصفيه التي حقق فيها شبه انتصار ولم
يخسر كما كان الكثيرون يتوقعون وبعد ان تم
استقرار في الصين بانتخاب الرئيس لفتره
خمس سنوات جديده يستطيع الان الرئيسه
التقدم بالنسبه الى
الملفات العالقه بينهما
سبايدر يهمه كثيرا ان يظهر بانه الرئيس
المسالم الرئيس الذي لا يريد اعاده فترات
الحرب البارده وهو رئيس يسعى الى همم
تحسين العلاقات مع جميع الدول خلافا لما
كانوا يفعله الرئيس السابق ترامب الذي كان
يتصرف بعفويه الرئيس يدرس الملفات يفكر
بالموضوع ويتعاطى بدبلوماسيه كبيره مع
الرؤساء الرؤساء الدول الاخرين والان
ستعاد النقاش من اساسه سيكون هنالك نوع من
الاحترام المتبادل لا اقول ان الجن جميع
الامور قد حلت اطلاقا لا ما زلنا في فتره
المزاحمه القويه بين البلدين ولكن الان
بعد هذا الاجتماع الذي كان اجتماعا يعتبر
صريحا جدا اعطيت الملفات الى فريقين فريق
من كل لدراسه الامور الخلافات العالقه
بروويه وبهدوء وبذلك يمكن لا انا شخصيا لا
اتا وقع ان تحل خلافات في المستقبل القريب
ولكن لن تتطور هذه الخلافات الى تصادم
والى ظروف صعبه سيئه وقد راينا ان الصين
ايضا تريد النفس شيئا نفسه هذا امر جيد
جدا براي انا شخص طيب عمرو شوبك المساله
الان او الاشكاليه الان هي في اعاده بناقه
بين البلدين وكان النبي محاوله
لفرز كل الخلافات تركجانبا ربما بحثا عن
اجماع خلال القمه
نعم اعاده بناء الثقه صحيح لانه نحن نتحدث
عن سنوات لم يلتق يعني لم يلتقي فيها
الرئيسيين
ونحن شهدنا ااا يعني ااا تفجر في درجه
الخلافات لم تاخذ فقط الجانب المعتاد وهو
جانب التنافس على اقتصادي والتجاري انما
شاهدنا خلاف عميق بين البلدين فيما يتعلق
بالحرب الروسيه في اوكرانيا شهيدنا خلافات
في حته الانتقاد المتبادل حين ظهرت رئيسه
مجلس النواب الامريكي
لتايوان همم
وشاهدنا حتى استعراضات عسكريه وتلويح
باستخدام القوه وما الى ذلك الفتره
السابقه كانت فتره همم صعبه ربما يشعر
الرئيس الامريكي انه هناك تقدم حدث للقوات
اوكرانيه في همم في همم بعد انسحاب القوات
الروسيه من خرسون وهناك احاديث نسمعها هنا
في فرنسا وتتابعها انه الحرب ستنتهي مع
دخول الشتاء القارس وانه سيكون هناك
تفاهمات و اا اتفاقات لن يكون من بينها
الاقاليم الاربعه التي احتلت اجزاء كبيره
منها روسيا انما سيكون التفاهم حول القرن
بشكل اساسي
والتي سبق وضمتها روسيا في 2014 اذا هناك
شعور انه همم الصين التي اتخذت موقفا حذرا
من دعمها لروسيا يعني نستطيع ان نقول انها
لم تتبنى الموقف الامريكي عيال روسيا
ولكنها لم
لمده
قبول مبدا الغزو المسلح وما الى ذلك همم
من هنا انا اتصور ان هناك صفحه
بهذا الكلام
الودي والايجابي عن عدم رغبه كلا
الرئيسيين في الدخول في في حرب بارده
جديده عوده مره اخرى لي فكره التنافس
الاقتصادي قبول الولايات المتحده وهذا هو
ما سيطرح في الفتره القادمه للصعود الصين
قوه يعني اذا راينا في اخر 30 سنه الصعود
الصيني ومعدلات نمو الصين اكبر مما هو
الحال في الولايات المتحده وبالتالي نحن
نتحدث عن منافسه ليست فقط على المستوى
الاقتصادي انما منافسه كمان لكلا
النموذجين على مستوى السياسي النموذج
الصيني بدا يروج لنفسه باعتباره النموذج
المركزي القادر على الانجاز في حين تعاني
الديمقراطيه الامريكيه من ازمات وهكذا نحن
عدنا الى الوطن
الطبيعي همم بدون
همم مواجهات وبدون احتقان سابق ولكن هذا
الوضع الطبيعي لا يخلو من تنافس
وسيفتح الباب امام منافسات همم كبيره في
المستقبل المنظور نامل جميعا نامل جميعا
الا تتحول الى مواجهات خاشنه او الى
منافسات خشنه المنافسه بالمعنى الذي نعرفه
التنافس التجاري الاقتصادي السياسي همم
دون ان تصبح منافسات خشنه كما شاهدنا في
الفتره الماضيه طيب يا نادر اريدك ان
تتفاعل مما يقوله عمره هل بالفعل الامور
عادت الى طبيعتها العلاقه اصبحت طبيعيه
بين البلدين يمكن ان يصدق هذا بسهوله يعني
بعد ثلاث ساعات خلاص عدت الامور الى
طبيعتها
اه يعني هذا هو يعني اتفاق بين التوافقات
بين قاده البلدين ولكن
تطبيق يعني توافق هذه توافقات فاعتقد يعني
رقم وجود الخلافات
اللي على الامريكيه الان تتجه الى
مسار ايجابي على الاقل يعني همم يعني هناك
يحتاج الى الوقت لتطبيقه ولكن بدايه ال
همم يعني بدايه جيده قد بدات همم يعني بعد
هذا الاجتماع
يعني هل يمكن مثلا
للسياسه الخارجيه الصينيه ان تتغير مثل ما
تريد ذلك واشنطن حيل كوريا الشماليه على
سبيل المثال حياله قضيه تايوان هذاك من
يعتقد بان عمليه استدراج للصينيين في
الملف الاوكراني حتى تقف الصيني الى جانب
الغرب ومحاوله على الاقل ايجاد تسويه
للحرب في اوكرانه
لا اعتقد ذلك لان السياسه الخارجيه
الصينيه هو سياسه مستق- يعني مستقله الصين
ايضا تتمسك بالسياسه خارجيه يعني همم
سلميه همم يمكن ان نقول التمسك بتنميه
سلميه فحاول القضايا العالميه الصين لها
الخاصه
الى السلام
والحل المشاكل عبر التفاوضات
في مثلا في شبه الجزيره كوريه الصين
تشجع الجميع اتراك الى المحادثات وكذلك سن
قدمت بيئه للمحدثات لحل القضيه وكذلك
تعارض يعني تتطلعوا الى السين وتدعم سين
اي اخلاء شبه الجزيره من الاسلحه النوويه
حول القضايا في اوكرانيا
النار وايضا
حاليا السلم والتشاجروا على جميع الاطراف
وخاصه
الى الاستئناف المفاوضات بين روسيا
اوكرانيا وكذلك همم
المفاوضات والحوار بين
روسيا
والولايات المتحده واتحاد اوروبي وكذلك
ترعى الصين ان الاولانيه الحاليه هو
الانتعاش الاقتصادي يعني بعد
سلبيه بسبب قرون همم يعني الكرونه فالع-
على ما يحتاج الى التعاون والتداون من اجل
تحقيق الانتعاش الاقتصاد العالمي الذي همم
الذي تتاثر سلبا في ال- همم
لذلك هذا هو يعني مواقف الصين وهي سلندر
لن تتغير ولكن هناك سيكون هناك همم اكثر
التفاهم مع الولايات المتحده طيب مسعود
معروف يعني هذا يعني تغير في الموقف
بمليون درجه من قبل بالتاكيد تتذكر كلمته
عندما دخل البيت الابيض وكيف ستكون
العلاقه مع الصين يعني كان صارما في حديث
الان تغير تقريبا المعطيات كليه هذه
الظروف التي يتحدث عنها الضيف في في بكين
يعني العالم يمر بها زمان يمر بازمه واحده
هي التي فرضت نفسها
طردت على بايدن ان يغير موقفه نسبيا
الرئيس بيضا يهمه كثيرا ان تحل العلاقات
ان تحل الامور الصعبه الامور العالقه بين
الدول بطرق سلميه هو معروف عنه كان رئيس
لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه في مجلس شيوخ لسنوات
طويله وعضوك ايضا في مجلس الشيوخ في لجان
الشؤون الخارجيه ومن هذا المنطلق هو رجل
دبلوماسيون بامتياز ولذلك هو يسعى قدر
المستطاع الى اسمه المساهمه في العمل
الدبلوماسي العالمي هذا لا يعني ان
الولايات المتحده ستنازل عن موقفها او
انها تطلب من الصين ان تتنازل الصين عن
موقفها ولكن هنالك تغير كبير في الاسلوب
في اسلوب التعاطي بين الدول وبين رؤساء
الدول وهذا امر
ايجابيا لان الاسلوب قد يسهله في حال حاله
الامور الصعبه اكيد اللي هنالك امور عالقه
قويه جدا بين الولايات المتحده والصين
الولايات المتحده تعرف جيدا ان الصين بعد
بضع سنوات ستصبح الاقتصاد الاول في العالم
والولايات المتحده تسعى الى البقاء في هذا
المركز ومن هذا المنطلق الولايات المتحده
والصين هنالك كثير من الامور التي لم تحل
حتى الان ويسعى الرئيس بيضا ربما بعد
التعثر الذي يراه الرئيس بوتين الذي نشهده
في الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا ربما يخشى
الرئيس بيضا ان يسعى الرئيس بوتن الى
استماره الصين اكثر واكثر لتؤيده اكثر
وليست تدعمه اكثر ويود من هذا المنطلق
التاكيد على الصين بان لا تسير في اتجاه
في مثل اتجاه نعم روسيا اكثر خاصه حاليا
تشتري الكثير من المواد البتروليه والغاز
وتساعد كثيره هذا ما يساعد كثيرا روسيا في
وضعها الاقتصاديه وفي مقاومه العقوبات
القويه المفروضه عليها هنالك ايضا امورا
تتعلق
بحريات العامه تتعلق بحقوق الانسان يطالب
بها الرئيس بين المهم الان ان حصل هنالك
تطور كبير في العلاقات الشخصيه بين
الرئيسين والان الملفات ستدرس بروويه
وبهدوء من الفريقين كل من فريق كل من
الدولتين ومن هذا المنطلق يمكن يصبح من
الممكن معالجه الامور او ربما عدم تركها
تتدهور اكثر واكثر لان كما شاهدنا
وبالسنوات الماضيه العلاقات بين الصين
وبين الولايات المتحده كانت تسير من سيئ
الى اسوء ربما الان سنستطيع ايقاف هذا
التدهور في العلاقات ونبني على ذلك في
المستقبل لكي لا الى حرب بارده جديده تمام
تمام يعني متفق فقط همم
يعني
همم لكن
ملاحظتي الاساسيه انه لا اتوقع مطلقا انه
الصين همم ستتراجع عن موقفها من شراء همم
الالغاز ومواد الطاقه الروسيه من اجل
الولايات المتحده هذا في رايي لن اه لن
يحدث همم بالضبط همم يعني
حتى لو طلبت الولايات المتحده واعتقد اشك
لان انا طوينا هذه الصفحه هذا ربما كان
وارد منذ عده اشهر همم انا من من يرون ان
الحرب همم اقتربت من نهايتها وانه فكره ضم
الاقاليم الاربعه همم يعني مساله غير
وارده انما الدور الصيني سيكون مطلوبا في
المساهمه في اخراج التسويه لانه هذه
التسويه اللي انت تكون سهله لان هناك
مطالب بالروسيه كما هو معروف قديما وهناك
ارض سيطره عليها روسيا حتى هذه اللحظه ومن
اماكن محصنه تحصينا شديدا
فاالفكره الدور الصيني في المرحله القادمه
سيكون دور مساهم في ايجاد مخرج وتسويه
في موقع قوه اكثر من الاخر هل هي الصين ان
الصين لعبت دور
يعني انها تشاهد ما الذي تقوم به هي الدول
الغربيه في مواجهه روسيا في الحرب في
اوكرانيا اذا هي ظلت على حياك حتى الان
الاخر هل هي الدول الغربيه هي اذا هي في
موقع الان الصين تريد ان تلعب دور الحكم
ولكن فكره التوازن كيف يستحقق التوازن هذا
هو السؤال ده هذا صحيح لكن هذا التوازن
سيكون توازن همم متقارب لانه حدثت تحولات
على الارض يعني
التحولات التي جرت في الاسابيع الاخيره في
صالح الجيش الاوكراني وفي صالح الدعم
والاسلحه والنموذج الامريكي الاوروبي الذي
وقف بكل همم ثقل وراء القوات الاوكرانيه
فنحن اصبحنا لسنا امام نقاش حول انتصار
روسي وسيطره الروسيه على اربع اقاليم بما
فيها خرسون انما نحن شهيدنا مجموعات روسيه
في الفتره الاخيره وبالتالي ما حدث على
الارض هو تغير لصالح الجانب الاوروبي
الامريكي في هذا الصراع من هنا همم نحن
مقبلين على تسويه هذه التسويه تحتاج كما
يتحدث كثير من السياسيين والمراقبين ان
روسيا في النهايه قوه عظمى لا يجب اظهار
الموضوع او اخراجه كانها هزمت هزيمه همم
نقراء همم وبالتالي هنا المساحه التي يمكن
ان تتحرك فيها الصين انه همم كيف يمكن همم
ايجاد مخرج لهذه نهايه هذا الصراع يرضي
يرضي الجانب الروسي وفي نفس الوقت همم
يعني يلبي مطالب المجتمع الدولي في هذا
الصراحه نقدر يعني بالصينيين يا روان
ويقولون انتم الان في مستنقع اوكرانيا اذا
تصرفوا مثل ما شئتم نحن صين يمكن انه يقدم
يد المساعده ولكن تقديم اصيل لهذه
المساعده لن يكون بالمواصفات
التي يريدها الغرب اذا ما الذي تنتظره
الصين تحديدا خاصه من هذه الازمه
طبعا الصين يعني تريد
هذه الازمه باسرع وقت ممكن يعني تحقيق
السلام
[موسيقى]
اوكرانيا
وحل هذه الازمه بطريقه
بشكل
[موسيقى]
تريد ان تقدم هل تخلق همم يعني الظروف
السلام في من ثقافه ما يمكن ما رايناه هو
اا اناس يعني قدمت جولات كثيره من مساعدات
الانسانيه اللي اوكرانيا وكذلك يعني همم
تدعوا للجميع اتراف
الى همم وقفه لكن النار
للمفاوضات طيب مسعود مسعود مسعود معلوف
يعني الان اوكي نريد ايجاد تسويه ولكن
عندما نسمع بايدن يقول لا نريد حربا بارد
جديدا لا يريد حرب بارده جديده هذا داخل
دائما في محاوله تنقيه الاجواء ولكن في
طريقه تمهد
لاشياء حتى الان
نعم هذا موقف الرئيس بيدن موقف موقفا علني
واضح لا يريد الرئيس
الولايات المتحده باداره الرئيس بيضا
العوده الى الحروب البارده الى حرب بارده
مع روسيا او الى حرب بارده مع الصين انها
زمن
البعيد ولكن اود ان اوضح نقطه عندما
الولايات المتحده والرئيس بيضا يعني ان
الصين تشتري الكثير من الغاز والبترول من
روسيا وهذا يدعم الاقتصاد الروسي لم اقول
ان الولايات المتحده ستطلب من الصين ايقاف
ذلك هذا امر غير وارد اطلاقا ولكن ايضا
يخشى ان تسير الصين بشكل ابعد من ذلك في
دعم روسيا في لمواجهه
جعوبات التي تواجهها روسيا حاليا وانا
اوافق مع الضيف الكريم الذي قال ان الصين
تستطيع ان تلعب دورا في تهدئه الاوضاع ان
تلعب دورا في في ماء الوجه في حفاظ ماء
الوجه لروسيا لا يجوز ان تخسر الروسيا
الحرب هذا امر غير مقبول عالميا لان ذلك
يمكن ان يؤدي الى مخاطر كثيره يجب ان نجد
مخرجا
مشرفا للجميع بحيث تنتهي هذه الحرب بشكل
لا يستطيع ان يقول احد انه خسر كثيرا وكله
واحده من الاطراف يستطيع ان يقول انه ربما
كسب شيئا هذا امر هكذا تنتهي الخلافات بين
الدول الرئيس بايدا يهمه كثيرا ان تنتهي
هذه
قصدك ان بيض ترمب يعني ههه
صعب ههه اه لا سمح الله لا سمح الله لا
علاقه مهروسه
ههه
عدم الدخول في مواجهه مع روسيا لا ترامب
كان له علاقات خاصه شخصيه مع الرئيس بوتين
وكان يتجنب كثيرا اي خلاف مع الرئيس بوتن
وهذا امر معروف عند كثير من الامريكيين
هنا يبدوا يقال هذا امر غير مؤكد ولكن
يقال انه هنالك ربما فضائح على الرئيس
ترامب عندما كان قبل ان يصبح رئيسا عندما
كان يقوم بعمليات ملكات الجمال في روسيا
ويقال انه هنالك امور وفضائح يتجنب الخوض
في خلافه مع الرئيس بوتين ولكن هذه الامور
غير مؤكده طبعا وليست من الامور السياسيه
العالميه الهامه ولكن الرئيس يركز كثيرا
على العمل
ميسي في حل الامور في حل العقد هو يدعم
كثيرا اوكرانيا الى اخر الطريق ولكن هذا
الامر مكلف على الولايات المتحده وعلى
حلفاء الولايات المتحده الاوروبيين ومن
هذا المنطلق يفضل ان تكون ان تنتهي هذه
هذه الحرب باسرع وقت ممكن طيب في بدايه
السنه في بيكين هل هذا تمهيد للقاء ربما
في الولايات المتحده او في الصين للرئيسين
لان مباشره بعد اللقاء اول اعلان ان
بلانكن سيزور بكين في بدايه السنه يعني
هناك يعني هذا سيعيد تقريبا لابد لنا
جميعا نعيدا النظر في كل ما
اتبعناه وفي كل ما درسناه في مجال
العلاقات الدوليه لو تغيرت المعطيات بهذه
الطريقه
نعم امر مهم جدا ان يقوم وزير خارجيه
الولايات المتحده بزياره الى الصين بعد كل
هذه الخلافات الواقعه بين الدولتين هذا خط
وهذه خطوه ايجابيه هامه جدا لا تعني ان
الخلافات ستحل ولكن ان هنالك
نيه لدى الطرفين بالعمل بالطرق
الدبلوماسيه على معالجه الملفات العالقه
بينهما لا لا نتوقع الكثير من الحلول لان
لكل دوله مصالحها الصين لها مصالحها
القويه سواء في اوراسيا وفي ومع روسيا وفي
افريقيا وفي امريكا اللاتينيه والولايات
المتحده ايضا لها مصالحها في العالم اثره
ومن هذا المنطلق لا نتوقع ان يتم حل جميع
الخلافات القادمه ولكن هذا الوضع يمكن ان
يؤدي الى عدم الى همم عدم المزيد من عدم
حصول المزيد من التداول في العلاقات والى
مراعاه كل فريق يراعي الاخر ويتفهم يتفهم
كل فريق مشاكل الاخر ومصالحه بحيث لا تؤدي
هذه الخلافات او هذه الاختلافات الى
خلافات على الارض هذا امر هام جدا زياره
لينكول الى الصين امر هام جدا برايي
لان انا قفزا على على الجغرافيا ولكن سنرى
قفزا على التاريخ همم
همم واعاده وموضوع العلاقات الدوليه اللي
اشرت اليه مهم انه همم يعني انا بتصور انه
العالم على مدار همم ما يقرب من قرن احنا
عيشنا القوه يعني القوه الاولى التي
تنافسها اكثر من قوه او اكثر من قطب دولي
وهي الولاد المتحده الامريكيه وانه
المنظومه الدوليه والمنظومه العالميه تكاد
تكون صممت على هذا
الفهم وهل الذي دعمه كثير من الامور
الواقعيه ما هو مطروح في السنوات القادمه
هو انه هذه المنظومه عليها ان تعترف ليس
بالضروره ان تصبح الولايات المتحده حتى لو
تقدم الناتج القومي للصين بعدد سكانها عن
امريكا لكن الاعتراف بان هناك قوتين على
مستوى العالم او ان هناك قوه منافسه
حقيقيه رغم انه روسيا سبقه الاتحاد
الاوروبي وهذا في حقيقه يحتاج همم الى
اعاده مراجعه واعاده همم
تاسيس جديد للنظام العالمي والمنظومه
الدوليه وهذا هو في راي القادم هو اكبر من
قضيه حرب اوكرانيا همم انما هو تاسيس
لمنظومه جديده فيها تنافس كبير لا يستطيع
ان توقفه زياره بلانكن او ال- انما منافسه
ناعمه ان تكون منافسه ناعمه وليست خشنه
وهناك ايضا تنافس على النماذج يعني هناك
من يرى في منطقتنا
وفي الشرق الاوسط جانب نفوذ وجانب انه هذا
النموذج الصيني اكثر نجاعه واكثر قدره على
الانجاز من النموذج الليبرالي الامريكي
همم
فنحن امام في الحقيقه همم جانب اخر هو
تنافس بين نموذجين النموذج الديمقراطي
الليبرالي الغربي الامريكي همم سيظل حاضر
وسي له تاثير ايضا
ونفوذ ولهو اا كثير من الناس تامل في
مجتمعات كثيره ان تبني نظم ديمقراطيه وما
الى ذلك لكن هي تواجه تحديات علينا ان نقر
بها واذا تاملنا مناطق كثيره في العالم
الحديث عن عوده السلطويه وما الى ذلك كل
هذه النماذج بعضها همم ياخذ الصين كانموذج
يتحدث على انه الحزب الواحد على انه هذا
الحزب الواحد قادر على العمل قادر على
الانجاز قادر على اتخاذ قرارات سعيعه غير
الديمقراطيات الرخوه وما الى ذلك
ما اقصده انه السنوات القادمه ستشهد تنافس
بين كلا النموذجين ليس فقط تنافس على
مناطق النفوذ ليس فقط تنافس اقتصادي
وتجاري ولكن نحن شاهدنا ذلك منذ ازمه
كرونه طريقه التعاطي معها طريقه همم تعامل
الدول المختلفه معها وهذا واقع علينا ان
نقر بيه في السنوات القادمه طيب نادر هل
هذا يعني ان الكلام الذي نطق به سجن بينك
في همم مؤتمر الحزب الشيوعي عندما شدد على
ضروره ان تلعب الصين دورا اساسيا في
السياسه الدوليه وفي العالم وان تكون لها
مكان
يعني تستحقه عن جداره هل هذا يعني ان
الرساله وصلت حتى الى الولايات المتحده
ااه اعتقد ان
يعني هذا هو ليس اا يعني كلام مواجهه
للولايات المتحده
فالصين همم
بصفاتها اكبر
الاقتصاد الثاني اكبر اقتصاد العالمي
وكذلك لها التقدم في كارتير من المجلات
فتريد ايضا المشاركه بشكل اكثر حيويا في
الشؤون الدوليه ولكن الصين هو دورها هو
الحفاظ على السلام
والتنميه السلميه يعني قدمت نموذج الاخر
يعني ليس ان النموذج الوحيد في العالم
لتحقيق الانجازات كما اكدت همم شيء في
كلماته في الاجتماع فانا الحريه
والديمقراطيه وحقوق الانسان هو اللقيه من
المشتركه التي عيلاتها البشريه وكذلك
الحياكيا التي تسعى اليها الحزب الشيوعي
الصيني فهناك التم كاراتيه الامريكيه وكنا
ايضا الديمقراطيه الصينيه همم وكلها تتفق
مع ظروفها يعني واقعيه
ولذلك يعني يجب على دولتين يعني احترام
هذا الاختلاف وكذلك اي اعتراف بهذا
الاختلاف وعدم السعي الى تغيير الاخر او
حتى اسقاط نظام اخر فيجب على الصين
والولايات المتحده التقدم معن قل لي همم
يعني تضامن للمواجهات التحديات العالميه
والتحديات البشريه كلها هذا هو همم ما
يريد ان ما تريد ان تؤكد عليها ف- همم
يعني همم حضر الاختلاف يعني كان موجود وسل
يستمر همم يعني
ولكن همم الان يجب على الدوله ايجاد
الطريقه الصحيحه للتعامل في المستقبل وهذا
التعامل يجب ان يعني يسب يصالحوا العالم
كله
فليتقدم
مشتركه والتنميه المشتركه فلذلك الصين
ايضا راحت يعني فكره مبادره بناء مصر
المشترك للبشريه مجتمع مصر مشتركه
الصين للحكم والاداره واللي تتطور
والتنميه في العالم
تتدخل لا تريد تداخل في شؤون الداخليه لاي
دوله ولكن تريد ان تقدم الحلول او حكمه
للعالم كله طيب مسعود معلوف يعني تابعته
ما يقوله الضيفين هو انه لكم دينكم ولي
ديننا مقاربتنا لمفهوم الديمقراطيه ولكم
مقاربتكم اتركون مع ديم وهذه ليست المره
الاولى التي يسمعها من السنين حتى عند عبد
الفتاح السيسي في شرم الشيخ قال له نفس
الكلام لنا مقاربه لحقوق الانسان فاسمعونا
هل هذا يعني ان هناك نزعه لدل امريكيين
للتخلي عن هذا المبدا مبدا محاوله
الترويج للديمقراطيه مثل ما تراها
الولايات المتحده
الولايات المتحده كانت تريد ان تعطي
نموذجها من الديمقراطيه ومن حقوق الانسان
ما تراه هي من الاحترام لحقوق الانسان
كانت تريد ان توزعه على العالم باسره همم
يبدو ان الان بدات الولايات المتحده تتفهم
اكثر واكثر بان هناك نماذج اخرى
للديمقراطيه لقد قال الرئيس السجن بصراحه
ان لكم
ديمقراطياتكم وعندنا ديمقراطيتنا على
الولايات المتحده انت تتفهم ذلك ليس هنالك
من نموذج واضح
للديموقراطيه ينبغي ان يفرض على جميع شعوب
العالم وحتى النموذج الديمقراطي الامريكي
حاليا هو يتصدع لقد سمعنا كثيرا في
الانتخابات الاخيره وفي الانتخابات
الرئاسيه الماضيه منذ سنتين هنالك يتعدى
على الديمقراطيه الامريكيه الرئيس ترامب
لم يقبل بنتائج الانتخابات التي كانت
انتخابات ديمقراطيه والان الرئيس بيدن في
حملته الانتخابيه لدعم حزب كان يركز على
الحفاظ على الديمقراطيه يعني بمعنى ان
الديمقراطيه هنا بدات تتهاوى هذه
الديمقراطيه الامريكيه ربما علينا ان نعي
في العالم كله ان هنالك ربما ينبغي ان
يكون نماذج مختلفه من الديمقراطيه لكل
مجتمع طريقه حياته فلا يمكن لنا كامريين
او كعرب او قصيين او قاروس ان نفرض
نموذجنا على الاخرين علينا ان نقبل بعضنا
البعض ولكن يبقى طبعا هنالك حدود بحيث لا
يتم القمع والقتل
والاضطرابات وهمم همم القيام باعمال ضد
اقليات باعمال قتل وسجن اقليات هذه اموره
غير مقبوله ولا تقبل بقاله هو اي نوع من
الديمقراطيات ولكن يبقى علينا ان نتفهم
بعضنا البعض وان نعيش بسلام مع بعضنا
متقبلين الديمقراطيه الصينيه والديمقراطيه
الروسيه والمصريه وغير ذلك هذه امورا
اعتقد انا انها ضروريه وعلى الولايات
المتحده ان تفهمها هذا ما اراهه
ومفهومه
حريه التعبير حريه الراي هذه الدرجه
الديمقراطيه يعني هو في نماذج مختلفه يعني
بلا شك انما هناك قيم اساسيه واحده يعني
اذا كما يعني اشار انه همم انه بلا شك انت
لا تستطيع ان تقول انه همم
اضطهاد الاف او مئات حتى الناس واقول انه
هذه همم
او انه تحت مسمى الخصوصيه الثقافيه
والحضاريه
ومن حق مجتمعات او دول بعينها تمارس
التعذيب او هكذا بلا شك هناك قيم انسانيه
يعني حاست عليها كل الثقافات والاديان
والنظم السياسيه بصرف النظر عن اختلافات
هذه النظم في احترام قيمه الانسان همم
الحريه الراي والتعبير عدم اضطهاد الناس
عدم سجنهم رفض الاستبداد المفارقه انه
فعلا ال- ال- التجربه همم ترامب يعني لمره
يعني حتى تجلي لها همم في البرازيل انه
الرئيس البرازيلي اليمين المتطرف اعترف
بالنتيجه نهاره رغم انه كان يعتبر ترامب
وهو يعني نموذج يستلمه في حاله ترامب في
الحقيقه كانت حاله يعني حتى في تاريخ
الولايات المتحده وتاريخ العالم همم
استثنائيه نتمنى حتى الا تتكرر ولكن
الديمقراطيات مثلا في امريكا الجنوبيه
موجوده رغم انها ديمقراطيه ناشئه وهكذا
الصين بلا هي نموذج نجاح ونموذج حزب واحد
قائم على همم لكنه قدم انجاز هائل على
المستوى الاقتصادي والسياسي كبير هل هذا
النموذج يمكن نسخه يعني يمكن تكرار الصين
او اخذ هذا الجزء الذي يعتبره البعض سلطوي
همم في بعض في بلادنا همم ويترك الجزء
الاخر المتعلق بالعلم والتكنولوجيا
والانجاز وما الى ذلك انا اعتقد انه نموذج
الصيني من وجهه نظري همم هو همم غير قابل
للاستنساخ هو يمكن الاستفاده منه يمكن
التفاعل معه لكنه هو الانسان تجربه
همم
للاسف لكن يعني انا اقصد انه في النهايه
هذا همم النموذج نتاج بلد احدث ثوره كبرى
عام 49 قام بمصار سياسي الثوره الثقافيه
في الستينات كان عنده زعماء
كبار من ماوتى كنتنج حتى الرئيس الحالي
وبالتالي هذا هذه التجربه بخصوصيتها همم
يجب ان تقدر وفي تقديري فكره انه تاخذ
الجزء
السلطوي او الجزء الذي
فيه جوانب اا يعني قمعيه او مركزيه همم
وتقول ستطبقه لا تستطيع ان تحقق ما حققته
سين في الاقتصاد لانه ه- في السياسه وفي
التكنولوجيا لان هذا نتايج تجربه اقترب
عمرها من 80 عام طيب نقدر الان انت بالنظر
الى سمعت ما سمعته في السابق خاصه من قبل
كل
المسؤولين عن الحزب الشيوعي في الصين وكل
ما يقال عن الولايات المتحده وعن
الامبرياليه الامريكيه وخاصه عادت هذه
العبارات بعد زياره نانسي فيلوزي الى
تايوان الان كيف يمكن ان تقنع ذهنيه
المواطن الصيني
بانه لابد ان يتغير الموقف نوعا ما بالنظر
الى تصحيح العلاقه بين الرئيسين
اعتقد يعني
هذا
يعني
معركه الشعبيه للولايات المتحده هو بسبب
الانتهاك الاستفزازات الولايات المتحده
للصين مثلا في همم يعني
وخاصه يعني زياره تونسي فلوس للجزيره بعد
انذار سن متكرر لذلك وهو تجاه النساء
وهذا هو طبعا همم يعني التحركات مثل هذه
ستثير الى شكل الغضب شعبي لدى همم مواطنين
سنين ولكن اذا كان الولايات المتحده تلتزم
همم يعني همم
يعني همم وقف همم الموا
الصينيون ايضا يريد التبادل فهو هم
منفتحون جدا
وحليا يعني ايضا يعني همم
متفاخرون
بانجازات التي حققتها الصين فهمم لان هم
يؤمنون بان الانفتاح هو مفتاح همم التقدم
فهذا يعني الان معروف او همم هو قد ضربت
جذورها في اعماق القلوب والدهن السنين
فلذلك همم الانسيون اصبح مفاتيح يعني
مقارنه همم يعني 40 سنه الماضي يعني ما
قبل 40 سنه
فاعتقد هناك يعني نوع من النار وكذلك همم
يعني
المواطنه فهموني ذلك لان
السيد مقاتحون لشراء
او مع الجميع والدول في العالم وهذا هو
مبدا الصين بتعامله للاعلاقات لموقف
الاستجاها العلاقات الدوليه باختصار مسعود
معروف سيكون من السارق نع الامريكيين
بالنسبه لبعيدا عندما يعود
السؤال
اعتقد انه لن يكون من السهل خاصه وان
الحزب الجمهوري حاليا ربما سيستطيع ان
يسيطر على مجلس النواب التابع للكونجرس
والشخص رئيس الاقليه حاليا التي ستصبح
اكثريه في مجلس النواب سيصبح هو رئيس مجلس
النواب كان مكارثي قد اعلن اليوم او امس
قال انه بعد ان يتسلم رئاسه مجلس النواب
طبعا في حال فاز الحزب الجمهوري بالاكثريه
سيقوم بزياره الى تايوان وهذا يعقد الامور
اكثر واكثر مثل ما تعقدت بعد زياره نانسي
فيلوزي ولذلك نعمل لا ينجح الجمهوريون
لانهم يريدون ان يعرقلوا سياسه الرئيس
بشطه الوسائل سواء في الامور خارجيه او في
الامور الداخليه وربما سنرى سيحصل في حال
فازوا بالاكثريه في مجلس نواب ام لا العمر
متوقف على ذلك
مستشار مركز الاهرام لدراسات السياسيه
والاستراتيجيه شكرا بكين لماذا
صحفي يمكنك ان تنام نوما هادئا للان
والشكر من واشنطن لمسعود معلوفه وخبير في
العلاقات الدوليه والدبلوماسي سابق الشكر
لفريق البرنامج امس يا مريحه للجميع
[موسيقى]